je sais que dans un an peut-être jeu
pourra plus marcher
[Musique]
je ne peux pas courir et je commence
même à avoir du mal à marcher
je peux même plus monter les escaliers
tout seul l' enveloppe de mes muscles al
amal fait donc quand je fais un effort
mon muscle ils se cachent plus vite donc
la force ça fait que j'ai moins de
muscles comme les autres bolides bas je
m'en sers 1600 je n'aime pas mais il est
pratique comme ça ne risque pas de
bouger
[Musique]
j'en veux en être humain avec tout le
monde on peut toujours trouver un
prétexte et le handicap c'est un
prétexte facile donc ces personnes je
m'en fiche je les écoute pas et je fais
comme presse comme celle ci n'existait
pas je suis très admirative en fait de
sa façon de gérer la maladie tout ce qui
va avec
en fait ils réussi à s'accrocher à ce
qui peut faire ce qui est envisageable
et à moins s'appesantir sur ce qui peut
plus faire ou ce qui pourra pas faire
bien sûr que c'est difficile et c'est de
plus en plus difficile mais on peut pas
abandonner c'est pas possible quoi ce
serait l'abandonner lui c'est impossible
il faut aller de l'avant et il faut voir
que ça a quand même des des points
positifs il ya des choses que je
n'aurais jamais pu faire sans cette
maladie par exemple récemment j'ai pu
assister à l'entraînement de l'équipe de
france à huis clos
je sais que dans pas longtemps un an
peut-être jeu pourra plus marcher
donc je profite un maximum
là il ya la partie visible les muscles
moteurs c'est les premiers affectés
c'est pour ça qu'il est de plus en plus
en fauteuil qui se déplacent de plus en
plus en fauteuil mais en effet peut-être
à long terme et laura une assistance
respiratoire parce que son diaphragme ne
marchera plus correctement
il aura peut-être des soucis cardiaques
également donc c'est pour ça qu'il a un
suivi pour toutes ces choses
mais à cause de ma maladie j'ai pris
lentement
donc j'ai une règle scanner ça me permet
de scanner le cours de copains et
ensuite de l'affiché sur l'ordinateur et
de d'imprimer et je le crois pour les
contrôles troisième faut faire de plus
en plus de résumer donc des gros textes
souvent 15 à 20 lignes et donc je vais
être dans une salle à part avec mon avs
et lui dicte ce qu'elle doit être fait
il écrit une personne qui m'a beaucoup
motivé c'est stephen hawking des
personnes comme ça qu'ils ont su
triompher de l'avc c'est un exemple pour
moi je voudrais bien être chercheur
parce que j'ai visité les laboratoires
du téléthon et tout ce qu'il faisait
pour la recherche pour un médicament
c'était fou mais c'est impressionnant et
je voudrais les aider pouvoir guérir des
personnes un peu il doit éviter de faire
des déplacements inutiles et du coup par
exemple je vais je vais par exemple
débarrasser la table à sa place ou faire
des trucs vraiment tout bête sa place je
sais qu'à plos à l'aide beaucoup et moi
ça me fait plaisir de l'aider parce que
je sais qu'à sa place je trouve ça sympa
que les que les gens disent non mais
c'est bon tu peux le faire
du coup je l'aide le mieux que je peux
cinq ans guerrier ouais il est très
courageux oui mais malgré tout ce grand
courage par moments on voit qu'ils
voudraient que les choses soient
différentes
et c'est à ce moment là qu'on doit
trouver quelque chose naturellement pour
que la vie continue pour qu'ils le
retrouvent le sourire mais on veut pas
que cette joie soit éteinte étouffée par
la maladie donc c'est là dessus qu'on
essaie de répartir tous les jours on
rigole beaucoup
on rigole beaucoup tous société vidéo
il est vraiment vraiment très fort très
intelligente du coup on aime beaucoup ce
jeu on y joue très souvent et c'est
agréable dans un temps de faire une
petite compétition en famille et ça fait
partie comme je disais des choses qui me
permettent d'oublier la maladie
alors là on va aller chez le kiné à
saint jean de bournay pour en faire des
exercices des étirements et des massages
partie du buzzer mois cet étirement que
j'aime pas et c'est un peu douloureux
mais après c'est c'est tellement
bénéfique quand on peut tout france
c'est pas mal mais c'est pas du tout
allait persévérer noir un noir parce que
ma
s est pas mal et dur et baisser les bras
ou qui ferait la tête quand mme verret
ou voilà mais pas pour l'autre ce côté
là sont supers sympas et est très
courageux les gens qui sont handicapés
ils doivent rester avec leur handicap
mais ce sont des gens comme les autres
ils ont envie de rire
ils ont envie de faire ils ont envie
d'exister et il faut pas les mettre de
côté
il faut leur permettre de réaliser je me
dis comment j'ai un handicap physique
mais comme dit ma mère le corps c'est
qu'une enveloppe ce qui est important
c'est ce qui est à l'intérieur
même si la vie réserve des mauvaises
surprises il faut toujours aller de
l'avant même si l'on voit toujours même
si des fois on n'arrive pas à le faire
c'est ce qui est plus important et
surtout faut pas vous garder espoir